PROFESSOR: We spent the
last few lectures developing
the theory of graph limits.
And one of the
motivations I gave
at the beginning of the
lecture on graph limits
was that there were
certain graph inequalities.
Specifically, if I tell you that
your graph has edge density one
half, what's the minimum
possible C4 density?
So for those kinds of
problems, graph limits
gives us a very nice
language for describing
what the answer is,
and also sometimes
for solving these problems.
So today, I want to dive more
into these types of problems.
Specifically, we're going to
be talking about homomorphism
density inequalities.
Homomorphism.
So trying to understand
what is the relationship
between possible subgraph
densities or homomorphism
densities within a large graph.
We've seen these kind
of problems in the past.
So one of the very
first theorems
that we did in this
course was Turan's theorem
and Mantel's theorem.
So specifically, for
Mantel's theorem,
it tells us something about the
possible edge versus triangle
densities in the graph,
which is something
that I want to spend the
first part of today's lecture
focusing on.
So what is the
possible relationship?
What are all the possible
edge versus triangle densities
in the graph?
Mantel's theorem
tells us something--
namely, that if your edge
density exceeds one half,
then your triangle
density cannot be zero.
So that's what Mantel's
theorem tells us.
And let me write
it down like this.
So the statement I
just said, the one
about Mantel's theorem, and more
generally for Turan's theorem
tells us that if the Kr
plus 1 density in W is 0,
then necessarily the edge
density is at most 1 minus 1
over r.
So this is what it tells us.
It gives us some
information about what
are the possible densities.
But I would like to
know more generally,
or a good complete
picture, of what
is a set of edge versus
triangle density inequalities.
So let me draw a
picture that captures
what we're looking for.
So here on the x-axis, I
have all the possible edge
densities, and on
the vertical axis,
I have the triangle density.
And I would like to know
what is a set of feasible
points in this box.
Mantel's theorem tells
us already something--
namely, when can
you-- so this region,
the horizontal line at
zero extends at most
until the halfway point.
Beyond this point, it's not a
part of the feasible region.
So far that's the
information that we know.
Our discussion about graph
limits, and in particular--
so let me first write
down what is the question.
So if you look at the set of
possible edge versus triangle
densities, so there
is this region here.
What is this region?
It's a subset of
this unit square.
We would like to
understand what is
the set of all possibilities.
The compactness of
the space of graphons
tells us that this
region is compact.
So let me call this region
D23 for edge versus triangle.
So D23 is compact because
the space of graphons
is compact under the cut
metric, and densities are
continuous under cut distance.
So in particular, if you
have some limit point
of some sequence of
graphs, that limit point's
achieved by a corresponding
limit graphon.
So you really have a nice
closed region over here.
So we don't have to--
I should be able to
tell you the answer.
This is the region.
There should not be any
additional quantifiers.
There's no optimizer
zero, missing this point
and missing that point.
It's a closed region.
So what is this closed region?
Equivalently, we can ask
the following question.
Suppose I give you
the edge density.
In other words, look at a
particular horizontal place
in this picture.
What is the maximum and minimum
possible triangle densities?
So I tell you that the
edge density is 0.75.
What is the upper and lower
boundaries of this region?
I want you to think about
why this region is--
the vertical cross-section
is a line segment.
You cannot have any hulls.
So that requires an
argument, and I'll
let you think about that.
So I want to complete
this picture,
and I'll show you some proofs.
And at the end of--
well, by the middle
of today's lecture,
we'll see a picture of what
this region looks like.
All right.
First, let me do the
easier direction, which
is to find the upper
boundary of this region.
So what is the maximum
possible triangle density
for a given edge density?
And the answer-- so it turns
out to be what I will--
the result I will tell
you is a special case
of what's called Kruskal-Katona.
Think about it this way.
Suppose I give you a very
large number of vertices
and I give you some
large number of edges,
and I want you to put the edges
into the graph in a way that
generates as many
triangles as possible.
Intuitively, how should
you put the edges
in to try to make as many
triangles as you can?
AUDIENCE: Clique.
PROFESSOR: In a clique.
So you put all the edges as
closely together as possible,
try to form a clique.
So maximize number of
triangles by forming a clique.
And that is indeed the answer.
And this is what we'll prove,
at least in the graph densities
version.
So we will show that the upper
boundary is given by the curve
y equals to x to the 3/2.
So don't worry about
the specific function.
But what's important is that
the upper bound is achieved
by the following graphon.
Namely, this graphon
corresponding to a clique.
For this graphon here, the
edge density is a squared,
and the triangle
density is a cubed.
And it turns out this
graphon is the best that you
can do with a given edge
density in order to generate
as many triangles or the most
triangle density possible.
In other words,
what we'll prove is
that the triangle density
throughout W will be a graphon.
So W is always a graphon.
So values between 0 and 1.
Then you have the
following inequality.
So let's prove it.
First let me draw you what
this shape looks like.
Because of the relationship
between graphs and graph
limits, any of these
inequalities about graph
limits, about graphons,
it's sufficient to prove
the corresponding
inequality for graphs
because the set
of graphs is dense
within the space of graphons
according to the topology--
namely, the cut metric
that we discussed.
So it suffices to show the
corresponding inequality
about graphs--
namely, that the K3
density in a graph
is at most the K2 density in a
graph raised to the power 3/2.
So let me belabor this point
just a little bit more.
This inequality is a subset
of those inequalities
up there because graphs sit
inside a space of graphons.
But because they sit
inside in a dense subset,
if you know this inequality
and everything is continuous,
then you know that inequality.
So these two are
equivalent to each other.
Now, with graphs--
and specifically,
these counts here, so triangle
densities and edge densities--
they correspond to counting
closed walks in the graph.
So in particular, if we're
interested in the number
of K3 homomorphisms
in a graph, this
is the same as counting
closed walks of length 3.
And there was important
identity we used earlier
when we were discussing the
proof of quasi-random graphs,
that for counting
closed walks you should
look at the spectral moment.
So that's a very
important tool to look
at the spectral moment--
namely, the third power
of the eigenvalues
of the adjacency
matrix of this graph.
This is the eigenvalues of
the adjacency matrix of G.
I claim that this sum
here is upper bounded
by a corresponding
sum of squares raised
to the power that normalizes.
The first time I saw this I
was a bit confused because I
remember, power
means inequality.
Shouldn't go the other way.
But actually, no, this
is the correct direction.
So let me remind you why.
So if you have a positive
t, then claim that--
and you have a bunch
of non-negative reals,
then the claim is
that this t-th power
sum is less than or equal to
the t-th power of the sum.
Now, there are several ways
to see why this is true.
You can do induction.
But let me show you one
way which is quite neat.
Because it's homogeneous
in the variables,
I can assume that the
sum is 1, in which case
the left-hand side is equal
to this sum of t-th powers.
So because I assumed that
everything is non-negative,
all these a's are
between 0 and 1.
So now, this sum is less
than or equal to the same sum
without the t's because
you're using it like that.
And that's equal to 1, which
is the right-hand side.
So this is true.
And now we have the
sum of the squares
of the eigenvalues,
which is also
a moment of the eigenvalues--
namely, corresponding to K2.
So the same inequality is
true for graph homomorphisms.
And to get to the
inequality for densities,
we just divide by the
number of vertices raised
to the third power
from both sides,
and we get the inequality
that we're looking for.
So that's the proof
of the upper bound.
Any questions?
There is something that bothers
me slightly about this proof.
Look, it's a correct proof.
So there is nothing
wrong with this proof.
Everything is kosher.
Everything is correct.
You might ask, is
there a way to do
this spectral
argument in graphons
without passing to graphs?
And yes, you can,
because for graphons you
can also talk about spectrum.
It turns out to be
a compact operator,
so that spectrum makes sense.
You have to develop a little bit
more theory about the spectrum
of compact operators, but
everything, more or less,
works exactly the same way.
It's just easier to
talk about graphs.
But what bothers
me about this proof
is that we started
with what I would
call a physical inequality,
meaning that it only
has to do with the actual
edges and subgraph densities.
But the proof involved
going to the spectrum.
And that bothers
me a little bit.
There's nothing incorrect about
it, but somehow in my mind
a physical inequality
deserves a physical proof.
So I use the word
physical in contrast
to frequency, which is
coming from Fourier analysis.
And that's the next thing
we'll do in this course.
But this proof goes
to the spectrum.
It goes to something
beyond the physical domain.
OK.
It's neat.
But I want to show you a
different proof that stays
within the physical domain.
And this other proof--
I mean, it's always nice to
see some different proofs
because you can use it to
apply to different situations.
And there are some
situations where
you might not be able to use
this spectral characterization.
For example, what if
your K3 is now K4?
A similar inequality is true,
but this proof doesn't show it,
at least not directly.
You have to do a little
bit of extra work.
So let me show you a different
proof of the upper bound.
And we'll prove a slightly
stronger statement.
Namely, that for all
not just graphons--
it's not so important but
for all symmetric measurable
functions, from the
unit square to r,
one has the following
inequality--
namely, that the
K3 density in W is
upper bounded by the K2
density of W squared raised
to power 3/2.
Here, the square is meant
to be a point-wise square.
So a couple of things.
If your graph is a
graphon or a graph, then--
if it's a graph, then
it's 0 comma 1 value.
So taking this point by
square doesn't do anything.
If you're a graphon,
you can always
put one more inequality that
replaces it by the thing
that we're looking for
because W is always
bounded between 0 and 1.
So it's a slightly
stronger inequality.
Let me show it to you by writing
down a series of inequalities
and applying the Cauchy-Schwarz
inequality repeatedly.
So it's, again, an exercise
in using Cauchy-Schwartz.
And we will apply three
applications of Cauchy-Schwarz.
Essentially, three
applications-- one
corresponding to every
edge of this triangle.
So let me begin by writing
down the expression in graphons
corresponding to the K3 density.
I'm going to apply
Cauchy-Schwarz by--
so I'm going to
apply Cauchy-Schwarz
to the variable x, holding all
the other variables constant.
So hold dy and dz constant.
Going to apply to dz.
You see there are two factors
that involve the variable x.
So apply Cauchy-Schwarz to
them, you split each of them
into an L2.
So one of these
factors become that.
By the way, all of these
are definite integrals.
I'm just omitting the
domain of integrations.
All the integrals are
integrated over from 0 to 1.
So the second
application-- sorry,
the second factor
becomes like that.
And the third factor
is left intact.
So that's the first
application of Cauchy-Schwarz.
You apply it with respect
to dx to these two factors.
Split them like that.
AUDIENCE: There's a
normalization missing.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
There is a
normalization missing.
OK.
Guess what the second step is?
Going to apply
Cauchy-Schwarz again, but now
to dy, to one more variable.
Cauchy-Schwarz
with respect to dy.
There are two factors now
that involve the letter y.
So I apply Cauchy-Schwarz
and I get the following.
The first factor now just
becomes the L2 norm of W.
The second factor
does not involve y,
so it is left intact.
And the third factor is
again integrated with respect
to y after taking the square.
And there's now dz that remains.
Last step.
You can guess, you
integrate with respect
to dz and apply Cauchy-Schwarz.
Apply Cauchy-Schwarz to
the last two factors.
And there, actually, the
outside integral goes away.
OK.
So you get this product.
And you see every single term
is just the L2 norm of W.
So you have that, which is the
same as what I wrote over here.
Any questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Where do you use
the fact that W is symmetric?
PROFESSOR: Great question.
So where do I use the
fact that W is symmetric?
So let's see.
In some sense, we're
not using the fact
that W is symmetric
because there
is a slightly more general
inequality you can write down.
And actually, the question
gives me a good chance
to do a slight diversion
into how this inequality is
related to Holder's inequality.
So this is actually one of
my favorite inequalities
for this kind of combinatorial
inequalities on graphons.
So many of you may be familiar
with Holder's inequality
in the following form.
If I have three functions,
if I integrate them,
then you can upper
bound this integral
by the product of the L3 norms.
And likewise, if you
have more functions.
So if you apply just
this inequality directly,
you get a weaker estimate.
So you don't get anything
that's quite as strong as what
you're looking for over there.
So what happens is
that if you know--
so if f, g, and h
each depends only
on a subset of the coordinates
in the following way
that f depends on only x and
y, g depends only on x and z,
and h depends only
on y and z, then
if you repeat that
proof verbatim
with three different
functions, you
will find that you
can upper bound
this product, this integral,
by the product of the L2 norms.
So L2 norms are in general less
than or equal to the L3 norms.
So here we're inside a
probability measure space.
So the entire
space has volume 1.
So this is a
stronger inequality,
and this is the inequality
that comes up over there.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there an entirely
graph theoretic proof of this--
say, for graphs instead
of graphons-- that doesn't
involve going to spectrum?
PROFESSOR: Great.
So the question is,
is there entirely
graph theoretic proof of this?
So the reason why I mentioned
that this result is a special
case of Kruskal-Katona--
so Kruskal-Katona actually
is a stronger result,
which tells you precisely how
you should construct a graph.
So given exactly m edges,
what's the maximum number
of triangles?
And the statement that
there is actually--
it's a very precise
result. It tells
you, for example, if you
have K choose 2 edges,
you have at most K
choose 3 triangles.
It's not just at the
density level but exactly.
And even if the number of
edges is not in the form of K
choose 2, it tells
you what to do.
And actually, the answer
is pretty easy to describe.
It's almost intuitive so if I
give you a bunch of matchsticks
and ask you to construct a graph
with as many triangles as you
can, what should you do?
You start with one,
two, filling a triangle.
Start filling a triangle.
Another vertex.
1, 2, 3, 4.
You keep going.
And that's the
best way to do it.
And that's what
Kruskal-Katona tells you.
So that's a more precise
version of this inequality.
And the Kruskal-Katona,
the combinatorial version,
is proved via a combinatorial
shifting argument, also known
as a compression argument.
Namely, if you start
with a given graph,
there are some transformations
you do to that graph
to push your edges
in one direction that
saves the number of
edges exactly the same
but increases the number
of triangles at each step.
And eventually, you push
everything into a clique.
So it's something
you can read about.
It's a very nice
result. Other questions?
So we've solved the upper bound.
So from examples and from
this upper bound proof,
we see that it's
the upper bound.
Now let me tell you a
fairly general result that
says something about graph
theoretic inequalities
but for a specific kind
of linear inequalities.
So here's a theorem
due to Bollobas.
I'm interested in an
inequality of the form like--
so I'm interested in
inequality of this form, where
I have a bunch of
real coefficients,
and I'm looking at
a linear combination
of the clique densities.
I would like to know if
this inequality is true.
So somebody gives
us this inequality,
whatever the numbers may be.
You can also have
a constant term.
The constant term
corresponds to r equals to 1.
So the point density.
That's the constant term.
And asks you to decide
is this inequality true.
And if so, prove it.
If not, find a counterexample.
So the theorem tells you
that this is actually not
hard to do.
So this inequality
holds for all G
if and only if it holds
whenever G is a clique.
Maybe somebody gives
you this inequality
about-- it's a linear inequality
about clique densities.
Then, to check this
inequality, you only
have to check over
all cliques G,
which is much easier than
checking for all graphs.
For each clique G this is
just some specific expression
you can write down,
and you can check.
So I want to show you the
proof of Bollobas' theorem.
It's a quite nice result.
But before that, any
questions about the statement.
All right.
So the reason I say that
this is very easy to check
if I actually give you
what the numbers are
is because this
inequality for cliques--
so the inequality is equivalent
to just the statement
of inequality that
I'm writing down now,
where I tell you precisely
what the r clique
density is in an n clique.
Because that's just some
combinatorial expression.
So to check whether
this inequality is
true for all graphs,
I just have to check
the specific inequality
for all integers n, which
is straightforward.
All right.
So let's see how to prove
that inequality up there.
And here we're--
I mean, we're not
going to exactly use
the theorems about
graphons, but it's
useful to think about graphons.
So if and only if one of
the directions is trivial--
so let's get that
out of the way first.
But also-- so the
only if is clear.
So for the if
direction, first note
that this is true for
all graphs if and only
if it is true for all graphons
and where I replaced G
by W. By the general theory
of graph limits and whatnot,
this is true.
So in particular, there
is one class of class
that I would like to look at--
namely, I want to consider
the set of node weighted--
so I want to consider the set
of node weighted simple graphs.
So node weighted
simple graphs, by this
I mean a graph where some
of the edges are present
and I have a node weight--
a weight for each node.
And to normalize
things properly,
I'm going to assume that the
nodes' weights add up to 1.
Now, you see that each graph
like that, you can represented
by a graphon where--
so you can have a graphon.
So they're not meant
to be the same picture,
but you have some graphon
like this, which corresponds
to a node weighted graph.
And the set of such
node weighted graphs
is dense in the
space of graphons.
In particular, as far as
graph densities are concerned,
they include all
the simple graphs.
So it suffices--
I mean, it's equivalent to--
the inequality is
equivalent to it
being true for all node
weighted simple graphs.
But for this space
of graphs, suppose
that the inequality fails.
Suppose that
inequality is false.
Then there exists a node
weighted simple graph.
I'm going to actually drop
the word simple from now on.
So node weighted graph H, such
that f of H being the above sum
is less than zero.
And there could be many
possibilities for such an H.
But let me choose.
So among all the possible
H's, let's choose
one that is minimal in the
sense that it has the smallest
possible number of nodes.
So with this minimum--
has a minimum number of nodes.
And furthermore, among all
H with this number of nodes,
choose the node weights, which
we'll denote by a1 through a n,
summing to 1.
Chooses node weights so that
this expression, the sum,
is minimized.
And by compactness--
and now we're
not even talking about compact
in the space of graphons.
You have a finite
number of parameters.
It's a continuous function.
So just by compactness,
there exists
such an H for which the
minimum is achieved.
This is minimizing
over integers.
And here, minimizing
over a finite set
of bounded real numbers.
So the name of the
game now is we have
this H, which is minimizing.
And I want to show that
H has certain properties.
If it doesn't have
these properties,
I can decrease those values.
So let's see what
properties this H must
have if it has the minimum
number of nodes and f of H
is minimum possible.
So first I claim that all the
node weights are positive.
If not, I can delete
that node and decrease
the number of nodes.
I would like to
claim that H must
be a complete graph because
if some ij is not edge of H--
so here i is different from j.
I do not allow loops.
It's just simple.
Then let's think about what this
expression f of H should be.
So I don't want to
write this down,
but I want you to
imagine in your head.
So you have this graphon H. I'm
Looking at the clique density.
It's some polynomial.
In fact, it's some multilinear--
it's some polynomial
in these node weights.
So I want to understand
what is the shape
of this polynomial as a
function of the node weights.
And I observe that it has
to be multilinear in--
has to be multilinear
in particular in
alpha i and alpha j.
It's a polynomial.
That should be clear.
It is multilinear
because, well, you have--
why is it multilinear?
Why do I not have
alpha i squared?
Either of you.
AUDIENCE: It says the
0 is not [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: So we're forbidding--
so here's alpha 1, alpha 2,
alpha 3, alpha 4, alpha 1,
alpha 2, alpha 3, alpha 4.
So understand what
the triangle density--
if you write down
the triangle density
as an expression in
terms of the parameters,
think about what comes
out, what it looks like.
And they essentially consist
of you choosing a subgraph,
which you cannot have repeats.
So it's multilinear.
So it's multilinear
in particular in alpha
i and alpha j.
So no term has the product
alpha i alpha j in it
because ij is not an edge.
So here's where we're
really using that we're only
considering clique densities.
So the theorem is completely
false without the assumption
of clique densities.
If we have a general inequality,
general linear inequality, then
the statement is
completely false.
So it's multilinear.
So if we now fix all
the other variables
and just think about
how to optimize,
how to minimize f of H by
tweaking alpha i and alpha j,
well, it's linear, so
you should minimize it
by setting one of
them to be zero.
And that would then decrease
the number of nodes.
So can shift alpha i and alpha
j while preserving alpha i
plus alpha j and not changing--
so not increasing
f of H. And then
we get either alpha
i to go to zero
or alpha j to go to
zero, in which case
we decrease the number of
nodes, thereby contradicting
the minimality assumption.
So this argument here then tells
you that H must be a clique.
So hence, H is complete.
And if H is complete, then as
a polynomial in these alphas,
what should f look like?
Well, it has to be
symmetric with respect
to all these alphas.
So in particular, it has to be--
so since H is complete, we
see that, in fact, now you
can write down
exactly what f of H
is in terms of the parameters
described in the problem.
Namely, it's Cr times
r factorial times Sr,
where Sr is a symmetric
polynomial where you look at--
you choose r of the
terms, r of these alphas
for each term in this sum.
It's just elementary
symmetric polynomial.
And I would like to know,
given such a polynomial,
how to minimize this number
by choosing the alphas.
But if you think
about what happens
if you fix again everything
but two of the alphas--
so by fixing all of, let's
say, alpha 3 to alpha n,
we find that--
so as a function in just
alpha 1 and alpha 2, f of H
has the following form.
And because it's
symmetric, these two B's
are actually the same.
So if we now vary alpha 1 and
alpha 2 but fixing everything
else, because alpha 1
plus alpha 2 is constant,
I can even get rid
of this linear part.
So that linear part is
fixed as a constant.
I want to minimize this
expression with alpha 1 plus
alpha 2, how it's fixed.
So there are two
possibilities depending on
whether C is positive or
negative or, I guess, 0.
So now you're here.
So depending if C is
positive or negative,
it's minimized by either the
two alphas equal to each other
or one of the two of
alphas should be zero.
The latter cannot occur
because we assume minimality.
So the first must occur.
And hence, by symmetry, if
you apply the same argument
to all the other
alphas, all the alphas
are equal to each
other, which means
that H is a simple clique.
It's basically an
unweighted clique.
So in other words,
if this inequality
fails for some H,
some node weighted H,
then it must fail for
a simple clique H.
And that's the claim above.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in the
statement, there
are two n's, are those two
n's different n's then?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Question.
There are two n's.
Yeah.
Thank you.
So these are two--
yeah.
So these are two different n's.
Great.
yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Which is the node weight
such that f of H [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: Question
is, why can we
assume that you can choose H
so that f of H is minimized?
Its because once--
OK.
So you agreed the
first thing you
can minimize because the number
of nodes is a positive integer.
So if there's a
counterexample, choose
the minimum counterexample.
Now, you fixed that number of
vertices, and the number of--
then this is an
optimization problem.
It's minimizing
continuous function
with a finite
number of variables.
So it has a minimum
just by compactness
of a continuous function.
So I choose that minimizer.
Any more questions?
So we have this rather
general looking theorem.
So in the second part
of today's lecture,
after taking a
short break, I want
to discuss what are
some of the consequences
and also variations of
that statement up there.
And I want to also show you
what the rest of this picture
looks like.
So let's continue to deduce some
consequences of this theorem
up there that
tells us that it is
pretty easy to decide
linear inequalities
between clique densities.
Namely, to decide it, just check
the inequalities on cliques.
So as a corollary for each n--
yes, for each n, the
extremal points--
so the extremal points of
the convex hull of this set
where I record the clique
densities overall graphons W.
So think about this set
as the higher dimensional
generalization of that
picture I drew up there.
But no previously we
had n equals to 3,
and we're still interested
in n equals to 3.
But in general, you have
this set sitting in this box.
And so it's some set.
And if I take the convex
hull of the set, what
that theorem tells us-- and
it requires maybe one bit
of extra computation.
But what it tells us is that the
extremal points are precisely
the points given by W equals
to Km for all m equal to 1.
So evaluate, find what
this point is for each m,
and you have a bunch of points.
And those are the convex hull.
So I'll illustrate by
drawing what the points are
for the picture over there.
But it essentially follows
from Bollobas' theorem
with one extra
bit of computation
to make sure that all
of these are actually
extremal points of
the convex hull.
None of them is contained
in the convex hull
of the other points.
So for example, we can
also deduce very easily
Turan's theorem.
So what does Turan's
theorem tell us?
It tells us that if the r
plus 1 clique density is zero,
then the K2 density
is at most 1 minus r.
So why does Turan's theorem
follow from the above claims?
It should follow because
all the data here has
to do with clique densities.
And everything we
saw so far says
that if you just
want to understand
linear inequalities
between clique densities,
it's super easy.
Maybe I'll draw the
picture for triangles,
and then you'll
see what it's like.
So the corollary tells
us for this picture,
corresponding to n
equals to 3, what
the points, the extreme
point of the convex hull are.
So let me let me draw
these points for you.
So one of these points
is this 1/2 comma 0.
So that corresponds
to Mantel's theorem.
Now, if you go to the
other values of m,
you find that those points--
so the extreme points--
they are of the form m minus
1 divided by m, m minus 1 m
minus 2 divided by m squared
for positive integers m.
So for m equals to 2, that's
the point that we just drew.
And the next point--
so next two points, one
third and one fourth,
they are at, if you plug it in--
thank you.
2/3 and 3/4.
They correspond to 2/9 and 3/8.
So let me show you
where these points are.
So they are at here
and over there.
And you have this sequence
of points going up.
So this is the convex hull.
And from that information,
you should already
be able to deduce
Mantel's theorem
because this right half is
not part of this convex hull.
So that's what Mantel's theorem.
And similarly, the
deduction to Turan's theorem
also follows by a similar logic.
OK.
So you have this
sequence of points.
Now, it happens that all of
these points lie on a curve.
So let me try to draw
what this extra curve is.
So there is some
curve, like that.
So there's some curve like that.
The equation of this curve
happens to be x 2x minus 1.
And because the
regions is contained
in the convex hull,
the yellow points,
it certainly lies above
this convex red curve.
You've seen this
red curve before.
From where?
So what is that saying?
It's saying that if your
edge density is beyond
above one half, then you
have some lower bound
on the triangle density.
Where have we seen this before?
Problem set one.
There was a problem on
problem set one that
says exactly this inequality.
So go back and
compare what it did.
But of course, the
convex hull result
tells you even a
little bit more--
namely, that you can
draw line segments
between these
convex hull points.
So you have some
polygonal reason that
lower bounds the actual region.
So what is the actual region?
So leaving you in suspense.
So let me tell you what
the actual region is now.
So it turns out to be
actually-- it's beautiful
and it's quite deep,
that the region is now
completely understood.
And it's a fairly recent result.
It's only about 10 years ago
roughly that there are
some concave curves.
The sequence of scallops going
up to the top right corner.
And this is now understood
to be the complete region
between these lower
and upper curves.
So this is the complete set
of feasible regions for edge
versus triangle densities.
So this lower curve
is a difficult result
due to Razborov.
And I want to give you a
statement what this curve is.
And Razborov came up with this
machinery, this technique,
known by the name
of flag algebra.
So actually, he came
up with this name.
So I won't really tell
you what flag algebra is,
but it's kind of a
computerized way of doing
Cauchy-Schwarz inequalities.
So many of our proofs for this
graph through inequalities,
they go through some
kind of Cauchy-Schwarz
or sum of squares equivalently.
But there are some very large
or difficult inequalities
you can also prove this way.
But it may be difficult
to find exactly what is
the actual inequality--
the chain of Cauchy-Schwarz
or the sum of squares that
you should write down.
So this machinery, flag
algebra, is a language,
is a framework for setting
up those sum of squares
inequalities in the
context of proving
graph theoretic inequalities.
So it can be used in
many different ways.
And notably, a lot of people
have used serious computer
computations.
If I want to prove
something is true,
I plug it into what's called
a semidefinite program that
allows me to decide what kinds
of Cauchy-Schwarz inequalities
I should be applying to derive
the result I want to prove.
So that's what flag
algebra roughly is.
So what Razborov proved
is the following.
So Razborov's theorem,
which is drawn up there--
that's the lower curve--
is that for fixed--
so for a fixed value
of edge densities,
if it lies between two
specific points, drawn above,
the minimum value
of triangle density
with a fixed value
of edge density
is attained via the
following construction.
It's attained by the step
function of the graphon
corresponding to a K clique.
So a complete
graph on K vertices
with node weights alpha 1
through alpha K summing to 1,
and such that the first K
minus 1 of the node weights
are equal.
And the last one is Smaller
All right.
And the point here is that if
you are given a specific edge
weight, edge density,
then there is
a unique choice of these alphas
that achieve that edge density.
And that is the graphon you
should use that minimizes
the triangle density--
describes the lower curve.
So you can write down specific
equations for the lower curve,
but it's not so important.
This is a more
important description.
These are the graphs
that come out.
And what is something
that is actually quite--
I mean, why you should
suspect this theorem is
difficult is that unlike Turan's
theorem-- so Turan's theorem,
which corresponds to all
those discrete points.
In Turan's theorem, the
minimizer is unique.
I tell you the number--
I tell you that the
edge density is 2/3,
and I want you to minimize
the number of triangles.
Not from Turan's
theorem, but it turns out
that this extremal
point is unique.
Essentially corresponds to a
complete three partite graph.
But for the intermediate
values, the constructions
are not unique.
So unless the K2 density
is exactly of this form,
the minimizer is not unique.
And the reason why
it is not unique
is that you can replace--
so what's going on here?
So you have this graphon.
Alpha 1, alpha 2, alpha 3.
I can replace this graphon here
by any triangle free graphon
of the same edge density.
And there are lots
and lots of them.
And the non-uniqueness
of the minimizer
makes this minimization
problem much more difficult.
So Razborov proved
this result for edge
versus triangle densities.
And this program was
later completed to K4,
and more generally,
to Kr So K4 is
due to a result of Nikiforov,
and the Kr result of Reiher
So a similar picture.
It's more or less
that picture up
there but with the
actual numbers shifted.
Instead of edge versus triangle,
it is now edge versus Kr.
I should say that it's worth--
so this is a picture that I
drew up there, and this is
roughly the picture that you
see in textbooks--
how they draw these scallops.
I once plotted what this picture
looks like in Mathematica,
just to see for myself
where the actual graph is.
And it doesn't actually
look like that.
The concaveness is very subtle.
If you draw it on a computer,
they look like straight lines.
So in some sense,
that's a cartoon.
So the concaveness
is caricatured.
So it's not actually as
concave as it is drawn,
but I think it's a good
illustration of what's
happening in reality.
Questions?
So on one hand, every
polynomial graph inequality--
so what do I mean by a
polynomial graph inequality?
So something like--
suppose I have
some inequality of this form.
And I want to
know, is this true?
It turns out that
I don't actually
need these squares in some
sense because I can always
replace them by what happens
if you take disjoint unions.
So all I'm trying to say is
that every polynomial graph
inequality can be
written as a linear graph
inequality of densities.
But nevertheless, this still
captures a very large class
of graph inequalities.
And if I just give you some
arbitrary one that is not
of that form, it
can be often very
difficult to decide
whether it is true or not.
So over here it's not so hard.
You just plug it
in, and then you
can decide whether it is true.
I mean, it turns out to decide
whether this inequality is
true, it's really a polynomial.
And then you just check.
It's not too hard to do.
But in general, suppose I give
you an inequality of this form.
So some generalized version of
a linear inequality, like that.
It's even decidable if
the inequality holds.
Decidable in the sense of
Turing halting problem.
So is there some
computer program
give you this
inequality is true?
I wonder, can you write
a computer program
that decides the truthfulness?
It turns out-- OK.
So before telling you
what the answer is,
let me just put it
in some context.
What about more classical
questions before we
jump into graph theory?
If I give you some polynomial
p over the real numbers
and I want to check
is that true--
so this is not too hard.
So this is not too hard.
But what if you have
multivariate for all real?
Does anyone know the answer?
Is this decidable?
So as you can
imagine, these things
were studied pretty classically.
And so it turns out
that every first word
or theory over the real
numbers is decidable.
So this is a result of Tarski.
In particular, such
questions are decidable.
And in fact, there is a very
nice characterization of--
so there's a result
called Artin's theorem
that tells you that
every such polynomial,
if it is non-negative,
then if and only
if, it can be written
as a sum of squares
of rational functions.
So there's a very
nice characterization
of positiveness of
polynomials over the reals.
But now I change the
question and I ask,
what about over the integers?
So if I give you a polynomial,
is it always non-negative
if I have integer entries?
Is this decidable?
So turns out, this
is not decidable.
And this is related.
So it's more or less the
same as the undecidability
of Diophantine equations,
which is also known
as Hilbert's tenth problem.
So there is no computer program
where we give you a Diophantine
equation and solves the
question or even tells you
whether the equation
has a solution.
And this is part of what
makes number theory,
makes Diophantine
equations interesting.
So it's undecidable,
but we talk about it.
So undecidability is a famous
result due to Matiyasevich.
So what about graph
theoretic inequalities?
So is a graph homomorphism
inequality decidable?
I mean, the question
you should ask yourself
is, which one is it closer to?
Is it closer to deciding the
positiveness of polynomials
over reals or over integers?
On one hand, you
might think that it
is more similar to the question
of polynomials over real.
So first of all, why it's
similar to polynomials,
I hope that's at
least intuitively--
nothing's a proof,
but intuitively it
feels somewhat similar
to polynomials.
And all of these guys
you can write down
as polynomial-like quantities.
And we saw this earlier in the
proof of Bollobas' theorem.
So you might think
it's similar to reals
because, well, for
graphons, you can
take arbitrary real weights.
So it feels like the reals.
So it turns out, due to a
theorem of Hatami and Norine,
that the answer is no.
It is not decidable.
And roughly the reason has
to do with this picture.
Even though the space of
graphons is not discrete,
it's a very continuous
object, even if you just
look at this picture
here, you have
a bunch of discrete
points along this scallop.
So here's a potential
strategy for proving
the undecidability of graph
homomorphism inequalities.
I start by just restricting
myself to this curve.
I restrict myself
to the red curve.
If you restrict yourself
to the red curve, than
the set of possibilities--
it's now a discrete set, which
is like the positive integers.
And now I start with--
I can reduce the problem to
the problem of decidability
of integer inequalities.
I start with an
integer inequality.
I convert it to an inequality
about points on this red curve.
And that turns into a
corresponding graph inequality,
which must then be undecidable.
So this undecidability result
is related to the discreteness
of points on this red curve.
So general undecidability
results are interesting.
But often, we're interested
in specific problems.
So I give you some specific
inequality and ask, is it true?
And there are a lot of
interesting open problems
of that type.
My favorite one, and also
a very important problem
in extremal graph
theory, is known
as Sidorenko's conjecture.
So the main cause conjecture--
it's a conjecture--
says that if H is bipartite,
then the H density in G or W
is at least the
edge density raised
to the power of the
number of edges of H.
So we saw one example
of this inequality
when H is the fourth cycle.
So when we discussed
quasi-randomness
we saw that this is true.
And in the homework,
you'll have a few more--
so in the next problem
homework, you'll
have a few more
examples where you're
asked to show this inequality.
It is open.
We don't know any
counterexamples.
And the first open example,
it's known as something
called a Mobius strip.
So the Mobius strip
graph, which is
a fancy name for the graph
consisting of taking a K55
and removing a 10 cycle.
So that's the graph.
It is open whether this
inequality holds for that graph
there.
And this is something
of great interest.
So if you can make
progress on this problem,
people will be very excited.
Now, why is this
called a Mobius strip?
This took me a
while to figure out.
So there are many
different interpretations.
I think the reason why it's
called a Mobius strip is
that if you think about the
usual simplicial complex
for a Mobius strip.
And then this is the face vertex
incidence bipartite graph.
So five vertices,
one for each face.
Five vertices, one
for each vertex.
And if you draw the incident
structure, that's the graph.
I'm not sure if this
topological formulation will
help you improving Sidorenko's
conjecture or disprove it,
but certainly that that's why
it's called a Mobius strip.
And there are some
people believe who
believe that it may be false.
So it's still open.
It's still open.
The one last thing
I want to mention
is that even though the
inequality written up there
in general is
undecidable, if you only
want to know whether
this inequality is true
up to an epsilon error,
then it has decidable.
In fact, there is an
algorithm that I can tell you.
So there exists an
algorithm that decides,
for every epsilon,
that resides--
so I just want to know whether
that inequality is true.
But I allow an
epsilon error, meaning
it decides correctly
this inequality is true
up to an epsilon error for
all G or outputs a G such
that the sum here is negative.
So up to an epsilon of error,
I can give you an algorithm.
And the algorithm follows--
I mean, it's not too
hard to describe.
Basically, the idea
is that if I take
an epsilon regular
partition, then all the data
about edge densities
can be encoded
in the epsilon
regular partition.
So apply even the weak
regularity lemma is enough.
And then we can test the
bounded number of possibilities
with some fixed number of parts.
And by the counting lemma,
you lose some epsilon error
if I check over
all weighted graphs
on some bounded number of
parts whose edge weights are
multiples of epsilon, let's
say, whether this is true.
If it's true, then it is
true with this epsilon.
If it is false,
then I can already
output a counterexample.
So there is only finitely
many possibilities
as a result of weak
regularity lemma.
And therefore, this
version here is decidable.
So today, we saw many different
graph theoretic inequalities
and some general results.
And there are lots of
open problems about graph
homomorphism inequalities.
So this concludes roughly
the extremal graph theory
section of this course.
So starting from
next lecture, we'll
be looking at Roth's theorem.
So looking at the
Fourier analytic
proof of Roth's theorem.